introducing the anatomic single bundle
ACL reconstruction procedure
arthroscopic surgical approach for
anatomic ACL reconstruction requires
three portals and anterolateral
an ant remedial and an accessory ant
remedial this standard and remedial
portal will be used for arthroscopic
visualization and should be placed close
to the patellar tendon and adjacent to
the inferior pole of the patella the
accessory ant remedial portal will be
used for drilling and should be lower
and more medial than the ant remedial
portal with the surgical markings in
place in size the ant remedial and
antral lateral portals
insert a con Medlin VTEC shaver to
excise any remaining ACL tissue
creation of the accessory and remedial
portal is made under direct
visualization with the arthroscope
placed in the anterolateral portal
looking medially with the knee flexed at
90 degrees palpate the medial joint line
under direct visualization insert a
needle just anterior to the medial
femoral condyle directed towards the
intercondylar notch the needle should be
above the medial meniscus to avoid
damage advance the needle to confirm
access to the femoral footprint of the
ACL
using an 11 blade incise the skin making
sure to orient the blade away from the
femoral condyle to prevent damaging the
articular surface switch the arthroscope
to the aunt remedial portal mark the
center of the femoral ACL footprint
using a micro fracture all
once marked use the bullseye native
footprint ruler to assess the footprint
of the native ACL stump
you
with the ACL footprint identified and
the center marked insert the bullseye
femoral footprint guide into the
accessory and remedial portal with the
knee flexed at 90 degrees place the
guide at the center of the ACL footprint
once the correct position is achieved
advance the guide pin into the femur a
few millimeters to notch the bone back
the guide pin out to check that the
guide pin correlates to the mark you
made earlier in the center of the
footprint using the guide to position
the guide pin hyperflex
and elevate the knee advance the guide
pin to the lateral femoral cortex noting
the aperture to cortex steps then
advance out of the skin continue
advancing the guide pin out through the
skin laterally using a twisting motion
to remove the femoral footprint guide
insert the mono fluted sentinel drill
bit over the guide pin through the
accessory and remedial portal with the
cutting edge facing away from the
femoral condyle and advance the drill
bit to the femoral ACL footprint
using a piston like back-and-forth
motion
advance the Sentinel drill bit to the
desired depth cautiously to prevent blow
out of the lateral femoral cortex pull
the drill bit back slowly until the
blade is visible in the joint space
keeping the hand off the trigger slide
the Sentinel drill bit past the medial
femoral condyle and out of the portal
making sure to keep the blade oriented
away from the condylar surface
using the Excel button drill bit to
drill the femoral Channel advance the
drill bit through the lateral cortex
using the EXO button drill bit as you
would use a standard depth gauge
manually pull back on the bit to hook
the head of the drill bit on the
external femoral cortex to confirm the
aperture to cortex length remove the EXO
button drill bit
leaving the graft passing guide pin in
place place the two free ends of the
number two passing suture through the
eyelet of the guide pin then pull the
guide pin through the femur laterally
making sure to keep a finger in the
suture loop to prevent it from being
pulled into the knee joint once the
suture ends are retrieved laterally pull
the looped end of the suture all the way
to the entrance of the femoral tunnel
switch the arthroscope to the
anterolateral portal next insert the
Lightwave ablator into the ant remedial
portal to mark the center of the tibial
ACL footprint set the angle the pin ACL
guide to 55 degrees insert the tip into
the ant remedial portal placing the tip
of the guide into the center of the
tibial ACL footprint next advance the
external guide sleeve flush to the
anterior tibial cortex using the con med
linda tech empower - handpiece and pin
driver attachment advance the guide pin
until it meets the point of the guide
arm then depress the pin ACL drill guide
lever to remove the sleeve remove the
pin ACL guide from the guide pin and
joint accurate can be placed over the
point of the guide pin to protect
against inadvertent advancement when
drilling be sure to use the appropriate
size badger or Sentinel drill bit to
drill the tibial tunnel
using the appropriate size se Graff
tensioner drill guide place the guide in
the tibial tunnel and position two
breakaway pins and then remove the guide
next place a probe into the accessory
and remedial portal to bring the loop of
the suture into the joint
retrieve the loop through the tibial
tunnel using suture retrieval forceps
with the suture loop exposed externally
load the suture strands of the EXO
button loaded graft into the passing
suture loop and pull them through the
femoral tunnel making sure to keep the
graft construct outside of the tibia
pull the EXO button loaded graft into
the joint and through the femur while
hyper flexing and elevating the knee to
ease the graft passage finally ensure
that the EXO button has flipped and is
seated
load the SE Graf tensioner suture
separator spread the whip stitch strands
radially as you load the SE graft
tensioner tying the appropriate bundle
strands to the left and right tensioner
wheels allows the bundles to be
individually and accurately tensioned
apply the desired graft tension and then
cycle the need to alleviate laxity hold
the knee at 15 degrees of flexion and
set the desired final tension next load
the appropriately sized Genesis matrix
onto the tri lobe driver ensure that the
knee is in 15 degrees of flexion advance
the Linda tech bio screw hyper flex
guide wire into the tibial tunnel and in
the center of the four graft bundles
load the matrix screw and driver onto
the guide wire and advance it through
the tensioner and into the tibial tunnel
until it is flush with the external
tibial cortex lastly remove the SE graft
tensioner and breakaway pins and follow
the normal procedures to close the
incisions note the anatomic position of
the final graft placement performing an
anatomic ACL reconstruction using the
accessory and remedial portal provides
improved rotational stability compared
to a non anatomic reconstruction ranging
the knee through flexion and extension
no graft impingement is observed
additionally with this technique a
knotch plasti is generally not needed
except of an unnatural anatomy such as
an a-shaped intercondylar notches
present
you